bonjour à toutes les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
alors les députés ont entamé hier soir à
l'assemblée l'examen du texte sur le
prolongement du délai de libérer elle
passerait donc de douze à quatorze
semaines un texte qui divise
profondément puisque près de 500
amendements sont à étudier cette semaine
ils ont été déposés à 90% par les
républicains un texte qui a été
présentée on va devoir par la députée
écolo anciennement république en marshal
bangai o elle est soutenue d'ailleurs
par le ministre de la santé regardez
aujourd'hui au moins 3000 femmes sont
chaque année contraint de se rendre à
l'étranger pour avorter mais d'autres
situations sont totalement invisibles
combien de femmes doivent continuer une
grossesse non désirée combien ont
recours à une ivg clandestine au péril
de leur propre vie nous ne pouvons
accepter situation en france en 2021 une
femme doit pouvoir avorter si elles le
souhaitent vous connaissez donc ma
position personnelle la position du
gouvernement
elle est aussi très claire elle consiste
à laisser la place aux débats sur vos
bandes parce que délibérer sur une telle
question relève pleinement de la
représentation nationale le gouvernement
quant à lui s'en remettra donc à votre
décision ce serait un avis de sagesse
qui sera porté par le gouvernement sur
l'ensemble des articles de ce texte de
loi que vous présentez un le
gouvernement qui ne prend pas position
cécile mu scotty quel est votre avis sur
cette question de de prolongement du
délai de livraison de 12 à 14 semaines
c'est à dire que mon avis ne dépend pas
de croyance j'ai été en charge d'une
mission parlementaire pour la délégation
aux droits des femmes une mission qui a
duré 18 mois dix-huit mois de travaux
qui nous ont permis de comprendre
qu'elle était réellement les freins et
d'identifier la problématique d'un accès
au droit d'un accès aux soins pour ces
femmes là nous ne sommes pas sur une
question de bioéthique
d'ailleurs le comité national d'éthique
a statué est favorable cet allongement
de douze à quatorze semaines puisqu'il
dit clairement qu' il n'y a aucune
évolution majeure entre 12 et 14
semaines que le geste médical reste le
même donc ça fait partie des leviers
c'est parce que lis tout à fait les
médecins on va en parler
après votre avis votre avis avoue
catherine de roche faut-il prolonger ce
délai nous avions
dans des affaires sociales que je
choisis la commission n'avait pas émis
un avis favorable de même que le sénat
sur l'allongement de douze à quatorze
semaines les avis en effet à midi au
centre d'une différence selon ceux qui
les portent et notamment l'académie de
médecine nous nous étions opposée à cet
allongement bien sûr il n'est pas
question de remettre en cause
l'idée ivg qui est maintenant passé
passé vraiment dans le droit mais
l'allongement elle sans poser des
questions à la fois sur le plan médical
que sur le plan d'eau du foetus lui-même
donc nous étions posé je suis un peu
surprise la position du gouvernement qui
d'habitude peut quand même avoir un
effet tranché lorsqu'il a fallu discuter
d'autres lois le gouvernement a un avis
très clair là on a l'impression qu'ils
n'osent pas je trouve ça très surprenant
comme attitude à part du ministre verra
pas les chiffres un conte à 230 2201
interruption volontaire de grossesse en
2019 c'est un taux record il a atteint
son plus haut niveau depuis 30 ans
comment expliquer cette hausse selon
vous cécile musko tive
on appelle une hausse si importante que
ça c'est un chiffre qui est relativement
stable depuis des années parce que de
toute façon une femme sur trois aura
rocourt ali vg au cours de sa vie c'est
un fait ça fait partie de la vie d'une
femme ça fait partie de son parcours de
santé à partir de là comment se fait-il
que cet acte médical soit considérée
autant à part vous allez me dire c'est
particulier c'est difficile c'est
compliqué oui mais il faut absolument
travailler sur cette levée de frein
alors on parle beaucoup de l'allongement
du délai mais il n'ya pas que ça il faut
augmenter l'offre de soins à l'échelle
du territoire donc permettre aux sages
femmes de pratiquer des ivg
chirurgicales est une autre possibilité
aussi il faut lever ces freins on est en
fait finalement dans un endroit qui est
formel et nous devons passer d'un droit
formel un droit réel pour ces femmes
françaises pour qu'elles puissent est
puisque puisqu'elle qu'elle puisse être
accompagné en toute sécurité partir à
l'étranger ce n'est pas sécurisant pour
une femme et puis ça en laisse beaucoup
sur le bord du chemin puisque je vous
rappelle que ces trois à cinq fois plus
cher qu'une ivg réalisées sur le
territoire national et dans des femmes
qui sont obligées d'aller avorter hors
de france ça concerne finalement que 1%
des cas faut-il une loi pour une
minorité se sont souvent d'ailleurs des
jeunes filles ou des des personnes qui
sont en en déni de grossesse selon les
médecins aurait-il pas mieux valu faire
finalement de la prévention selon vous
cécile mu scotti
bien sûr qu'il faut travailler sur les
questions d'éducation sexuelle de
prévention autour de la contraception
est là dans notre rapport de la
délégation aux droits des femmes ça fait
partie d'un certain nombre de
préconisations qui touche au code de
l'éducation
mais des choses qui existent déjà j'ai
envie de vous dire si les établissements
scolaires
respecter finalement ce qui est écrit
dans les textes c'est à dire avoir deux
séances par an pour venir discuter
expliquer comment fonctionne la
contraception se parler de sexualité de
manière libre on n'en serait peut-être
pas là et les freins serez peut-être
moins important et surtout le tabou un
petit peu lever en parle dit vg ça met
tout le monde mal à l'aise ça fait
partie de la vie d'une femme je vous le
disais une femme sur trois donc bien sûr
qu'on a des leviers de prévention à
travailler mais en revanche travailler
sur l'offre de son à l'échelle des
territoires la sécurité des femmes pour
qu'elles évitent de partir à l'étranger
et puis nommé dans une moyenne
européenne on n'est pas né pas les
français les fous qui veulent faire
sauter une barre en matière de délais
d'avortement on est dans un moyenne
basse de l'europe est passé de douze à
quatorze je le répète le copiste le
comité national d'éthique n'y voit
aucune aucun danger aucune difficulté
d'un point de vue scientifique
catherine de roche le fait que ce soit
une loi finalement pour une minorité de
femmes on l'a 10 1% des des cas la
plupart des femmes cadres dans 99% des
cas
font une interruption de grossesse très
rapidement donc faut-il légiférer
ce que la prévention et l'enseignement
de ce qu'est la sexualité la
contraception le
la vie sexuelle doit être renforcée il y
a en effet des dispositifs qui le font
pour ma part lorsque je présidais la
mission santé à la région des pays de la
loire nous avions mis en place un pass
contraception mais également un pass
santé et vie sexuelle avec des
consultations pour éviter justement ces
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
qui touche qui touchent des jeunes
filles est en effet l'offre de soins
elle doit être
augmenté si une femme on arrive à
vouloir dépasser le terme légal actuel
est-ce qu'elles n'ont pas sur le
territoire l'offre de soins mais je
pense que l'on prend un problème un peu
à l'envers sous prétexte qu'il y à ses
freins on se dit bon on va augmenter
l'âge légal et si dans deux ans nous dit
qu'il ya encore un pour cent des femmes
qui sont au-delà du nouvel de la
nouvelle barrière de gros les deux
semaines de grossesse que l'on aura fixé
on montre encore donc ça peut être en
effet sans fin et utilise est à partir
d'un certain seuil non pas sur une
interruption médicale de grossesse qui
peut être faire lorsqu'il ya en effet
deux les conditions psychologiques
graves il le précise mais on est sûr
volontaire de grossesse en revanche ce
qui est de la prévention et je partage
ce qui est dit la sexualité à l'école
puissent passer dans les textes et les
enseignants membres doivent être faire
en ce sens doit participer à réduire à
réduire le nombre d'interruptions
volontaires de grossesse qui se font
quoi qu'on en dise toujours dans une de
façon douloureuse pour la femme qui le
fait je ne porte aucun jugement sur les
femmes qui le font bien sûr c'est dans
les textes c'est dans la loi le verra
toujours pas question de remettre en
cause mais je pense qu'il faut être très
très vigilant sur les allongement du
délai c'est l'argument de de nombreux
médecins qui se disent contre
effectivement cécile musko tissé de dire
finalement comme on a rendez-vous très
tard très tardivement surtout à paris il
faut évidemment prolonger ce délai parce
que les rendez vous sont donnés trop
tard à certaines femmes
ya la question des rendez vous trop tard
il ya la question du délit d entrave via
la question du manque d'information
notamment sur internet c'est à dire que
vous avez des associations militantes
anti ivg qui vont monter leur système
d'information pour faire croire à la
femme qui voudrait un rendez-vous et
être reçue que la démarche est
enclenchée sauf qu'en fait elles vont se
retrouver baladé pendant de longs jours
et chaque jour et précieux dans ces
moments là elles ne vont pas être reçu
par un médecin qui veut pratiquer une
ivg et elles vont comme ça perdre du
temps dans leur cheminement et ça ce
n'est pas acceptable c'est pas
acceptable dans une réalité de questions
d'accès au droit aux droits des femmes
ce n'est pas acceptable d'un point de
vue philosophique et politique qu'on
puisse laisser comme ça des militants
rétrograde prendre le pouvoir et donc il
faut qu'on travaille sur cet ensemble de
de levier là et c'est ce que propose ce
texte de loi on je le répète vous disiez
c'est une loi qui s'adresse hamilton
minorité de femmes non
démultiplier l'offre de soins mettre en
place un répertoire unique par les ars
agences régionales de santé pour que
chacun puisse trouver le bon praticien
le plus près de chez lui possible ça
fait partie des éléments qui vont
effectivement raccourcir les délais pour
que liv et j'ai se passe le plus entre
guillemets facilement possible mais il
faut aussi laisser la possibilité à ces
femmes là et qui sont pas forcément des
jeunes filles pas au fait de la
contraception ou des filles issues de
milieux défavorisés qui se retrouvent à
dépasser les délais vous savez ce sont
souvent des femmes c'est ce que dit le
rapport entre 25 et 35 ans qui ne sont
plus dans un projet de grossesse qui ont
un moyen de contraception et qui donc ne
vont pas identifier les signes de
grossesse et quand elles se rendent
compte et bien c'est trop tard
quelles réponses nous devons apporter
nous la france à ces femmes là quelles
réponses sécurisé en matière de soins
nous devons leur apporter telle est la
question notamment l'allongement des
délais alors les médecins on l'a dit son
inquiète pour la santé de leurs
patientes pratiquer une ivg à 14
semaines c'est très difficile on a dit
sur le plan médical et psychologique il
faut extraire un enfant déjà formés
c'est ce que font valoir certains
médecins une ivg tardives seraient
nocives écoutez
j'appelle les politiques à venir
assister à une ivg tardives
ils ne tiendront pas deux minutes
comment peuvent-ils décidé sans l'avis
des médecins de quelque chose qui est
dangereux pour les femmes au quatrième
mois le foetus est aussi fier et
difficiles à extraire ses sinus cotisent
7h et cet aspect psychologique très
difficile 1 pour ces femmes qui est qui
font des ivg tardives et ce qu'il est
pris en compte par par les députés qui
vous soutiennent bien sûr qu'il est pris
en compte et la loi de toute façon
propose un examen psychologique à toutes
ces femmes et qui permet finalement de
rajouter un garde et un délai de
réflexion de deux jours après
l'excellent examen psychologique
évidemment qu'il l'est mais il est aussi
parce que de nombreuses femmes sont
maltraités dans leur parcours ivg
maltraités parce qu'on les juge mal
traités parce que on ne les accueille
pas dans des conditions dignes parce qu
on les culpabilise de cette décision
qu'elles ont prises et qu'elles ne sont
pas pris en charge de manière correcte
après ce que dit ce médecin je l'invite
vraiment à lire le rapport parlementaire
18 mois de mission des déplacements
partout en france à l'étranger pour
essayer de comprendre de nombreuses
auditions de gynécologues obstétriciens
de praticiens qui pratiquent l'ibg de
ceux qui ne veulent pas la pratiquer on
n'est pas parti comme sa bille en tête
en disant on sait pas quoi faire cette
semaine au parlement et s'ils ont
allongé les délais dit vg absolument pas
c'est le fruit d'une vraie réflexion et
d'un vrai travail donc comme vous le
comprenez ça met un petit peu en colère
d'entendre ce genre d'éléments des anges
appellent les parlementaires mais c'est
ce que nous avons fait ceci le travail
que nous avons produit il ya une tribune
un tir de deux médecins d'ailleurs qui
en appelle à emmanuel macron qui lui
s'est prononcé clairement contre
libéré il donne évidemment au parlement
le fin mot
catherine de roche qu'elle est quel est
votre sentiment sur cette sur ses
quatorze semaines qui serait nocif ce
tant sur le plan physique que
psychologique pour pour les femmes non
il est clair que plus on augmente les
délais plus le foetus et et formés et
plus les difficultés peuvent être là ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est le premier
le président de la république et contre
son ministre dit qu'il est pour c'est
très compliqué je ne vois pas pourquoi
il ya cependant de 2 un peu de faire en
catimini des oiseaux ou le courir devant
la scène
moi j'étais opposé à l'allongement du
lait en revanche sur tout ce qui a été
dit par ma collègue député bien
évidemment qu'il ya des choses à revoir
dans la prise en charge par rapport à
ces femmes qui seraient mal orientées
par rapport aux possibilités d'avoir
accès à ce que la la loi autorise il
n'est en effet des programmes ou sa
butte au niveau du parlement et du sénat
notamment c'est sur la glace que sur cet
allongement de durée pour le reste pour
que ce que les facilitations d'un droit
existant il est bien normal que puisque
ce droit existe on doit arrêter femmes
dans les conditions de pouvoir y accéder
alors il ya un autre aspect dans ce
projet de loi c'est une c'est la clause
de conscience spécifique d'aidé soignant
et dans une tribune publiée ce mois-ci
près de 3000 personnels médicaux ont
appelé emmanuel macron à intervenir
regarder
on ne peut forcer un professionnel à
agir en contradiction formelle avec sa
conscience il s'agit d'un droit
fondamental des soignants qui sont tenus
d'agir en responsabilité et de manière
éclairée leur fusée serait contraindre
certains professionnels de santé à
abandonner leur métier à l'heure où les
professionnels de santé sont
particulièrement sollicités et le
système de santé gravement fragilisé
remettre en question un de nos droits
les plus fondamentaux est
particulièrement malvenu cécile
muscatiers ce que cette loi vise aussi à
supprimer cette cette clause d'ailleurs
des gynécologues ont dit qu'ils ne
pratiquerait plus cet acte s'il était
prolongé à 14 semaines mais absolument
pas moi je suis atterré de lire tout ça
parce que en fait ces professionnels
n'ont pas lu le texte de loi nous ne
supprimons pas la clause spécifique de
conscience ali vg elle est réécrite pour
être conforme à celle de lee mg qui a
été voté par le sénat le projet de loi
bioéthique
et que dit cette clause spécifique de
conscience elle commence en ces termes
en cas de refus en cas de refus le
praticien devra réorienter sa patiente
et donc à aucun moment nous oppose
allons obliger ou sanctionner un médecin
ou à faire un acte qu'il ne voudrait pas
faire pour des raisons qui lui sont
personnelles morale religieuse et ça
c'est important de le dire donc ils
pourront continuer à refuser il y aura
les médecins qui pratiquent les gestes
ceux qui ne pratiquent pas les vg en
revanche il est plus acceptable de ne
pas avoir une réorientation
vers un collègue qui lui pratiquer une
ivg et ça je le raccroche à la création
de ce répertoire unique qui facilitera
l'accès à l'information pour que le
médecin puisse dire goûter voilà moi
pour des raisons qui me regarde je ne
fais pas dit vg en revanche voici à tel
endroit ou à telle personne on vous
pouvez vous vous adressez quête voilà ce
qu'on change dans la loi catherine de
roche une réaction à cette clause de
conscience spécifiques à risque ou pas
selon vous moi je pense qu'il doit
demeurer en effet on ne peut obliger un
praticien à faire un acte telles que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
qui consiste en effet à
interrompre une grossesse alors que le
médecin a en général pour objectif que
la grossesse parce que mu possède donc y
ait cette clause de conscience
spécifiques il faut la maintenir alors
la réorientation
en effet je pense que c'est une bonne
une bonne solution après le quid si la
patiente n'est pas un peu orienté ou n'a
pas accès aux
professionnels que leur a désigné si
c'est une liste comment est-ce qu'il
faut bien vérifier c'est que le
professionnel ne puisse pas être mis en
cause c'est une fois qu'il a annoncé son
refus il donnait la liste de
professionnels qui pratiquent interne
sur volontaire de grossesse la femme ne
peut pas le faire il faut que
ce médecin ce soir à protéger sur le
plan sur le plan responsabilité il faut
qu'il ait la preuve qu'il a bien donné à
la personne d'une liste de médecins qui
pratiquent mais il ne faut pas qu
ensuite et puisse lui être reproché quoi
que ce soit si la suite nassen ne serait
pas parce que 10 c'est un risque de
poursuite si la volée le devoir de
réorientation ne serait pas fait ou pas
non il n'y a aucun amendement dans le
texte de loi qui prévoit une quelconque
sanction pénale en cas de de non respect
en tout cas rien qui ait rajouté aux
droits existants évidemment les
praticiens en ce devoir de respecter la
loi telle qu'elle est
et donc les sanctions sont les mêmes
pour tous mais ne rajoutons aucune
sanction supplémentaire dans ce texte
merci beaucoup à tout les deux d'avoir
débattu de ce prolongement de lives et
de douze à quatorze semaines ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france les
débats vont se poursuivre bien sûr toute
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale
merci à toutes les deux c'est la fin de
cette première partie de matinée